MALE SPEAKER: I
would like everyone
to give a nice warm welcome
to Timothy Jordan, who
is going to be talking about
Google Glass. [APPLAUSE]
And we will start.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
How is everyone?
Todd just asked, but I'm
asking again for form's sake.
Good?
OK.
Hey, I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm a developer advocate
working on Glass.
And you can find out more
information about me,
and we can have a chat if
you visit me over at Google+.
google.com/+timothyjordan.
Today, I wanted to talk
a little bit about games,
because that seems to be
the right context for it.
But I have a few
questions first.
And this is going to start
with a really easy one.
This is partially because of
the question, and partially
to just know who in the audience
is going to participate today.
Who likes games?
OK, everyone's going
to participate today.
I like that.
Now here's a more deep
leading question, if you will.
Who here believes that the
average game on a smartphone,
when just ported to Glass, is
going to make sense on Glass?
And no one.
Now I know because you're paying
attention, because you already
demonstrated you're
participating.
And that's the thing, is
that our gaming systems
look nothing like this.
And I'm going to
spend some time today
talking about the
user interaction
model and the
paradigms with which we
design things for Glass.
And how that becomes
a challenge when
we think about building
games on Glass.
I'm going to start out with
some general principles that
are the foundation for how we
think about Glassware design
or apps for Glass design.
Those of you who have seen
the design principles before,
please bear with me.
They're still new
for some people.
And then after that, I'm going
to drill down just a little bit
deeper into some do's and
don'ts, specifically based
on those principles, but
looking at games in particular.
Sound like fun?
Whoo!
It's just after lunch,
and we're excited.
Design principles.
So, there's five of them.
And the first one is
the most important.
This is design for Glass.
And what we mean by this
is design specifically
for the Glass platform.
Because although
it's a mobile device,
it's fundamentally different
than other mobile devices.
It's not a rectangle
with a touchscreen on it.
That's clear and obvious,
but when I say it out loud
it makes more sense, or
at least that it should.
And it goes deeper than just
how it gets put on user.
The UI changes because of that.
So, this is the Google+
experience on a tablet
and on a phone.
You can see it's a very
browsable experience.
It's very much lean
back on your couch,
see what your friends are up to.
But when the user's
wearing Glass,
they're out in the world,
they're doing others things.
They might still want
the benefit of technology
and the cool stuff and Google+.
But they're going to want
it in a different way.
So, this is that same
experience, that same service,
but on Glass.
You'll notice a handful
of things are different.
First off, there's a
single thing per view,
and it's very glanceable.
I briefly look at
this, and I know
it's a post from my
friend Alex, who's
on a steep climb on his bike.
I need less than a second
to figure that out.
And if I want to
interact with him,
I can, through some very
short and quick gestures.
The thing here is that
it's the same service,
but it's different on Glass.
It's been rethought and
redesigned specifically
for this experience.
And most importantly,
it's been tested on Glass.
And we've made changes.
In fact, when I've been
working with developers outside
of Google-- some of our
partners and otherwise--
most of the time spent
building Glassware
is in that iteration phase.
After they've thought
what the design would be.
They've built the prototype,
and then they put it on Glass,
and they go, oh.
And then we started
changing things together
until we got to a good place.
So, the four
following principles
really build upon that
theme, designing specifically
for Glass.
And the first one is
don't get in the way.
And this is especially both
important and challenging
when we're thinking
about game design.
The idea is that I'm out in
the world doing something,
and I might use Glass to
enhance that experience.
In this case, I'm looking
at some jellyfish,
and I'm learning
more about jellyfish.
You don't see something else
blocking my vision here.
Now, with game
design, we're used
to the paradigm of immersion.
Capture the user's attention,
engross them in the game,
and keep them there.
And usually, the success
metric is the more time
they spend there, the more
involved and immersed they are,
the more valuable the game.
The more they enjoy it.
The more they keep coming back.
With Glass, that's different.
Because you're getting in the
way of the user's life while
they're out there living it.
So, we need to start
thinking about how do we
build games that
highlight this difference,
not fight this difference.
And I'll talk more about that.
Keeping it relevant.
And there's two
very specific ways
we think about
this in common use.
One is over time, and
the other is over space.
Because relevancy has a
lot to do with what now is.
And when you're thinking about
different computing paradigms,
your cloud is your
sort of forever.
Your laptop might be your
last year, two, or three.
However often you replace them.
Your phone could be the
last month or the last week.
But Glass is right now.
It's just this moment, and
it's where you happen to be.
This is one of my favorite
ideas for building
for Glass is having a
shopping list when I need it.
I don't know about you,
but I keep a shopping list.
But every time I'm at the store,
that shopping list is somewhere
else.
And so what I've started
doing is I keep it digital.
But wouldn't it even be cooler
if when I get to the store--
and maybe I check
in, or Glass just
knows that I'm there
because I've been there
for a few minutes-- it
surfaces my shopping list
with the items that can
be found at that store.
How exceedingly
helpful would that be?
And that's because
it's an experience that
can know where I am and help me
out in that particular moment.
We want to avoid the unexpected.
Especially the unexpected
and the unpleasant.
Because the unexpected and
the delightful is good.
Surprising our
users with delight
is fantastic,
especially when looking
at entertainment or gaming.
But giving them
something unexpected
that they also do not enjoy?
That would be unfortunate.
And it's particularly important
to remember this on Glass
because it's so
personal to the user.
They're wearing Glass
throughout their day.
So, when you come and
say hello to them,
it's something that should
be helping them in their day.
It's not something that you
can remind them of abstractly
while they're at their desk.
Because that's not where
Glass is most often used.
A great way to do this is to
give users controls and make
it clear what's
going to happen when.
And an example is CNN, where
CNN delivers short videos
throughout the day on the
topics that I've chosen.
And to choose those topics,
I go to the settings page,
and I can choose the
different topics.
I get an idea of how many posts
per day I will get per topic.
And I can also choose the
time of day that I can receive
notifications, and when I don't.
So I have a lot of the agency.
I have a lot of
choice as a user here.
Or I can tell CNN when
I want to get this news.
And so when that
news comes through,
it's an expected part
of the experience.
And the last thing
is build for people.
This is something
that we discuss a lot,
especially nowadays.
I think it's really important
to mention, especially
in the context of Google Glass.
And this is what I mean by this.
And I suspect most of the people
in this room already know this.
That the layout on
your keyboard was
designed to make
you type slower.
Who knew that?
So not everybody.
About 40%.
Isn't that extraordinary?
Doesn't it bother you on
some level, just a bit?
Now, I'm not saying the
keyboard's going to go away.
We're familiar with
it, and it's sort of
like this universal
input device.
However, that layout
was designed at a time
that mechanical
typewriters were the norm.
And if you typed too
fast, they'd jam.
So the layout was meant to keep
typists from going so fast.
And in that way, actually get
more work done on the day,
because they didn't
have to deal with jams.
But that's not really
the case anymore.
And we've done some
incremental improvements,
like lighting the keyboard, or
making the keys a little bit
more low-rise so that you
can type a bit faster.
But Glass is not an
incremental improvement.
It's what we call a moon shot.
It's a 10x improvement.
And this is where
Glass users are.
They're out living their
dreams on adventures
or doing the things
that make them happy.
They still want the benefit
of technology in their lives.
So the question we've got to
ask ourselves as the makers
and designers and
developers of this Glassware
is how can we give them that
joy of technology, while not
getting in the
way of their life?
Always thinking about where's
the user going to use this.
Who are they around?
How can we make it
fun for everyone?
And those are them.
Those are the
foundational guidelines
for building Glass
software or Glassware.
Designing specifically for
Glass and testing it on Glass.
So that we really know what
works and what doesn't.
Not getting in the
way of the user.
Never taking precedence over
anything else in their life.
Keeping it relevant to where
they are, what time it is.
Avoiding the unexpected.
And especially that which is
unexpected and unpleasant.
And finally,
building for people.
Solving real user problems.
Building games for people
to use in their lives.
OK, so a few notes coming off
of this, specifically for games.
Who has had a
chance to use Glass?
OK, so just about
20% of the audience.
The obvious things are
relatively obvious.
For input, we've got a touchpad.
There are microphones,
I can use voice control.
There's a camera.
There's a full IMU.
And of course, there's
location services.
And for output,
I've got a screen.
It's always there
when I want it.
It's never in my line of
sight, but it's always
in my field of view.
It's 640 by 360.
And of course, there's
audio, either through earbuds
or through the built-in
audio that's just for me.
And those things are
interesting, but even more
so is how the form
factor changes
how you use those items.
Because those input
and output mechanisms
are on other devices,
but it's different
when you put it in Glass
and you wear it outside.
So let's drill down into some
of those do's and don'ts, if you
will.
And the first one is
don't design an app.
There's two important
points here.
First, the Glass UI
model is time-based.
It's not an app model.
At no point will you
find a wall of icons
that you can choose to launch.
Instead, we use voice commands.
And these voice commands
aren't launch maps.
It's get directions to.
It's an action.
It reduces the time between
intent and that action.
So instead of "launch
maps, enter an address,
tell it where I am, I want
directions by car," I just say,
"get directions to
the Moscone Center."
And it happens.
And all voice commands
follow this form.
A note about voice commands.
These voice commands
are built models
that we release with
software releases,
and there's a set number
of them that are growing.
One of them that you may be
interested in is "play a game."
And if the user has
multiple games installed,
they then get to choose
which game, again by voice.
Don't just port your
mobile experience to Glass.
So this is a screenshot
that we haven't actually
shown very much.
This is an early
prototype of Glass.
The idea, what if
Glass was a dashboard
and we showed the user a lot
of information all the time?
So we tried it.
It's important to try things
quickly and when they fail,
learn from them and move on.
And this failed.
Right?
It's too much information.
If I'm going to sit
down at my desk,
I'm fine with looking
through a lot of information.
But if I'm walking
between meetings,
this is not going to work.
It's a glanceable interface.
And so even though you might be
trying to have the same action
or give the same benefit
to the user, how you do
it is going to be
different on Glass.
And you want to test this
experience everywhere you can.
An example of that is
both indoors and outdoors.
This one image, when
seen through Glass
inside and outside, looks
remarkably different.
And it's not just the luminosity
against the background.
It's also the color temperature.
A little more detail there.
White is the new black, which
is also the name of my upcoming
first album, "White
is the New Black."
The white right
there, you'll notice
is very stark in its contrast.
It's really easy to see, whereas
the black part of the screen
sort of fades into
the background.
And we establish hierarchy
with different shades of color.
Green, red, different
shades of gray.
You wouldn't want to do this
by changing the font size,
because smaller font sizes
can be hard to read on Glass.
So you'll notice
there's a heading here,
and then there's
different data that's
differentiated and broken
up visually by using color.
But the font stays
the same size,
and it's the same font face.
Be wary of head gestures.
And the reason for this
is that it might not
work out the way
you think it will.
Because head gestures-- when
I'm standing still and not doing
anything else-- are
relatively predictable.
But when I walk down the
street, everything changes.
And to emphasize this point,
here's a video of a chicken.
Humans don't operate this way.
And this is another one of those
cases where what you need to do
is if you're going to try
head gestures, go for it.
Write the experiment,
and then go try it.
Try it in several
different environments
and different locations.
Make it glanceable.
The interesting thing
about these two screens
is that I put these
in front of people,
and I'm like, which do
you like better, which
has more information,
which is more usable?
And opinions differ.
The thing is, on
the left, you've
got so much visual information
that even though some of it's
useful, it takes you a
longer time to get there.
Whereas on the right,
what you need to know
you can get in just a glance.
In fact, in about half the time.
If you want, you can try
and break it into chunks.
On the left, there's all
these different places
where your eyes are
going to go before you
realize the entire picture.
And on the right, there's
just a handful of them.
We can even put some
numbers behind this.
On the left side,
you're going to see
in an average of 1.8 seconds.
On the right side,
half that time.
And it's the same information.
It's the same
usage for the user.
But how we've displayed it
is remarkably different.
And because of that, you also
want to design for emotion.
It can be simple.
It can just be telling the user,
you're doing good on your run.
Keep going.
And finally, include
other people in the fun.
This might not be
so obvious when
we're doing video game design.
But I think it is obvious
when we do board game design.
You know?
Think about the last
game of Werewolf or Mafia
that you played.
You had the game master,
you had the people
who are participating.
And you had the people
who are watching,
hanging out in the background.
It was fun for everybody
to see that game unfold.
What if Glass were like that?
Here's a photo I recently
took of my team playing
a word game, something
like Taboo, using Glass.
Glass was the
interface for this that
just made the game move along.
But then it was the people
that were really the mechanic.
There's been a lot of game
design for Glass done already.
In fact, Glu released
this great game
on Glass, called Spellista.
It was a great start for seeing
how to use the Glass interface
and gives the user
an opportunity
for whimsy on Glass.
Not just productivity.
And we recently released
some experiments
for trying different
sensors out.
And using new kinds
of game play based
on those sensors and the
form factor of Glass.
And the next step
is for all of you
to figure out how
to make this happen.
What I mean by this is that
the next step in Glass gaming
design is not going
to look like a game
on your phone or your tablet
or even like a board game.
It's probably going to look
a lot more like IRL games.
But it's going to include
this component that
makes it all that much
more engaging for the user
and for the people around them.
And our job is to
work on this stuff
and make sure the
platform is flexible,
and you can do some
amazing things with it.
And I'm just waiting
for and hoping for
and here to encourage.
What does innovation on
games for Glass look like?
And the next big step
where everybody sort of
stops and says, oh, that's
what it is, has yet to happen.
Which means you
guys are probably
the ones that are
going to do it.
It's going to
happen any day now.
For more information on the
product and the platform,
developers.google.com/glass.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]